>>> THERE IS BREAKING NEWS
TONIGHT.
NEW REPORTING FROM "THE
WASHINGTON POST" ON JU HOW
SENSITIVE SOME OF THE DOCUMENTS
RECOVERED FROM MAR-A-LAGO
ACTUALLY WERE.
NOW, I'M QUOTING FOR THE
HEADLINE OF "THE WASHINGTON
POST."
MATERIAL ON FOREIGN NATIONS
NUCLEAR CAPABILITIES SEIZED AT
TRUMP'S MAR-A-LAGO.
THE SUBHEAD READING, SOME SEIZED
DOCUMENTS WERE SO CLOSELY HELD,
ONLY THE PRESIDENT, A CABINET
LEVEL, OR NEAR CABINET LEVEL
OFFICIAL COULD AUTHORIZE OTHERS
TO KNOW.
NOW WE'RE TRYING TO CONNECT WITH
ONE OF THE REPORTERS ON THE
STORY RIGHT NOW.
>>> THERE'S ALSO THIS JUST IN.
MARK WARNER SAYS HE AND HIS
MEMBERS ARE EXPECTING A BRIEFING
SOON FROM THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE ON SENSITIVE DOCUMENTS
RECOVERED FROM MAR-A-LAGO.
CHAIRMAN WARNER INDICATING TO
CNN'S MANU RAJU THAT HE IS
TRYING TO GET AN UPDATE WITHOUT
WAITING FOR A FINAL REPORT.
>>> MEANTIME, ON JUDGE AILEEN
CANNON'S RULING THAT A SPECIAL
MASTER BE APPOINTED TO REVIEW
THE MATERIALS, LISTEN TO WHAT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY
GENERAL SAID ABOUT IT LAST NIGHT
ON FOX.
>> THE OPINION, I THINK, WAS
WRONG, AND I THINK THE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD APPEAL IT.
IT'S DEEPLY FLAWED IN A NUMBER
OF WAYS.
I DON'T THINK THE APPOINTMENT OF
A SPECIAL MASTER IS GOING TO
HOLD UP.
>> WHEN OR WHEN AN APPEAL COMES
IS ONE QUESTION.
WHETHER IT SHOULD IS ANOTHER.
SO IS THE QUESTION OF WHETHER
JUDGE CANNON'S RULING GIVE THE
FORMER PRESIDENT BETTER
TREATMENT THAN OTHERS MIGHT GET
UNDER SIMILAR CIRCUMSTANCES.
LET'S TALK ABOUT IT WITH FORMER
FEDERAL JUDGE NANCY GERTNER.
ALSO DAVID URBAN, WHO SERVED AS
POLITICAL STRATEGIST TO THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
AND JENNIFER RODGERS, CNN LEGAL
ANALYST AND FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR.
JENNIFER, FIRST OF ALL ON "THE
WASHINGTON POST" REPORTING, WE
DON'T HAVE MORE DETAILS OR WE
CAN'T INDEPENDENTLY CONFIRM WHAT
"THE WASHINGTON POST" IS
REPORTING, BUT ON JUST.
>> IT'S CONSISTENT WITH SOME OF
THE REPORTING WE'VE HEARD BEFORE
THAT THERE ARE VERY, VERY
HIGH-LEVEL, HIGHLY CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS HELD AT MAR-A-LAGO.
NUCLEAR SECRETS ARE AMONG THE
MOST CLOSELY HELD IN GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT'S
BEEN OUT THERE ALTHOUGH WITH
MORE DETAIL.
I DO WONDER HOW IT'S GETTING OUT
AND WHO'S LEAKING IT.
I THINK IT'S PROBLEMATIC IF
THOSE LEAKS ARE COMING FROM
INSIDE THE GOVERNMENT.
BUT IN TERMS OF THE GOVERNMENT'S
CASE, YOU KNOW, LISTEN, THIS IS
THE KIND OF DOCUMENT THAT YOU
WOULD CHARGE A CASE ABOUT, AND
IT'S NOT A DOCUMENT THAT'S GOING
TO BE SUBJECT TO ANY SORT OF
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE OR
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
SO WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
DOCUMENTS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
AVAILABLE TO THE GOVERNMENT TO
CHARGE CRIMINALLY IF THEY
CHOOSE, THIS IS THE SORT OF
DOCUMENT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> I WANT TO BRING IN ONE OF THE
REPORTERS ON THE BYLINE ON "THE
WASHINGTON POST" REPORTING.
CAN YOU JUST TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU
HAVE LEARNED?
>> RIGHT.
SO WE HAVE LEARNED THAT WHEN THE
FBI CONDUCTED ITS SEARCH ON
AUGUST 8th, OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
BEEN COURT DOCUMENTS DESCRIBING
A LOT OF CLASSIFIED MATERIAL
THAT WAS TAKEN.
WE'RE TOLD THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS FOUND IN THE COURSE OF
THAT SEARCH WAS A DOCUMENT THAT
DESCRIBED A FOREIGN GOVERNMENT'S
MILITARY DEFENSES, INCLUDING ITS
NUCLEAR CAPABILITIES.
AND OBVIOUSLY THAT WAS A CAUSE
FOR SOME CONCERN ALTHOUGH
THERE'S A LOT OF MATERIAL IN
THIS TRANCHE OF STUFF THEY
SEARCHED FOR AND FOUND THAT IS A
CAUSE FOR CONCERN.
>> IN THE ARTICLE, YOU DETAIL
THE KIND OF PROCEDURES WHICH
WOULD NORMALLY BE PUT IN PLACE
TO PROTECT SUCH A DOCUMENT.
>> RIGHT.
SO WE'RE TALKING THE MOST
SERIOUS CATEGORY OF THIS TYPE OF
INFORMATION IS WHAT'S REFERRED
TO OFTEN AS SPECIAL ACCESS
PROGRAMS.
>> SO THIS IS ABOVE TOP SECRET
CLEARANCES?
>> IT'S SORT OF A VERY TIGHT
CIRCLE WITHIN THE LARGER CIRCLE
OF TOP SECRET IF THAT MAKES
SENSE.
IT'S A TYPE OF TOP SECRET
INFORMATION IN WHAT'S BEEN
DESCRIBED TO US AS SOME OF THE
S.A.P. MATERIAL THAT WAS SEIZED
WAS SO CLOSE HOLD THAT ONLY THE
PRESIDENT, SOME CABINET
SECRETARIES, AND NEAR
CABINET-LIKE OFFICIALS WERE
AUTHORIZED TO SHARE OR ALLOW
OTHER PEOPLE IN THE GOVERNMENT
TO SEE THAT KIND OF INFORMATION.
SO EXTREMELY CLOSE HOLD,
EXTREMELY TIGHTLY HELD.
AND THERE WAS AN ALLUSION TO
THIS IN ONE OF THE COURT FILINGS
IF YOU REMEMBER.
ONE OF THE FILINGS SAID THAT
EVEN THE INVESTIGATORS WHO
RECOVERED THE MATERIAL, SOME OF
THEM WEREN'T -- EVEN THOUGH THEY
WERE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE AGENTS,
SOME OF THEM WEREN'T AUTHORIZED
TO REVIEW SOME OF THE DOCUMENTS
WHEN THEY FIRST FOUND THEM.
>> SO SOME OF THE FBI AGENTS WHO
WERE ON THE SCENE IN MAR-A-LAGO,
THEY DIDN'T EVEN HAVE THE KIND
OF CLEARANCE THAT WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO LOOK AT THESE DOCUMENTS?
>> CORRECT.
AND NOT JUST THE AGENTS, SOME OF
THE FEDERAL PROSECUTORS INVOLVED
IN THIS MATTER ALSO DIDN'T
AUTOMATICALLY HAVE A CLEARANCE
TO LOOK AT SOME OF THE THIS
MATERIAL.
THAT'S HOW CLOSE HOLD IT WAS.
>> AND YOU TALK ABOUT CLOSE
HOLD, WHO WOULD BE ABLE TO SEE
IT AND WHO WOULD GRANT THAT
AUTHORIZATION, WHETHER IT'S
EITHER THE PRESIDENT OR CABINET
LEVEL OR NEAR CABINET LEVEL
OFFICIAL.
THESE ARE ALSO DOCUMENTS THAT
HOW THEY ARE STORED, OBVIOUSLY A
LOT OF THOUGHT IS PUT INTO THAT.
>> RIGHT.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT DOCUMENTS
THAT SHOULD BE STORED IN A SCIF.
IT'S A GOVERNMENT ACRONYM FOR A
VERY SECURE ROOM AND SHOULD HAVE
SOMEONE WHO'S DESIGNATED, A
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL DESIGNATED
TO KEEP VERY CLOSE TABS ON THOSE
KINDS OF DOCUMENTS.
THAT'S ANOTHER CAUSE FOR CONCERN
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY WHEN THEY
CONDUCTED THIS SEARCH, THEY
LOOKED IN A STORAGE ROOM.
THEY LOOKED IN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S OFFICE.
YOU KNOW, THOSE AREN'T NEARLY
THE KINDS OF PLACES WITH THE
KINDS OF SECURITY FOR DOCUMENTS
LIKE THAT.
>> HAS THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
LEGAL TEAM RESPONDED TO YOUR
REQUEST FOR COMMENT?
>> WE HAVE NOT HEARD BACK FROM
THEM YET.
OBVIOUSLY WHEN WE'VE DONE PRIOR
REPORTING ON THIS QUESTION OF
NUCLEAR WEAPONS MATERIAL,
NUCLEAR WEAPONS INFORMATION, THE
PRESIDENT CALLED IT A HOAX.
AND IN THAT SAME STATEMENT
SUGGESTED THAT EVIDENCE WAS
PLANTED ON HIM BY THE FBI
AGENTS.
>> OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT CLEAR WHY
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE
HAD THIS INFORMATION AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
THERE'S A WHOLE MYRIAD OF
REASONS, BUT OBVIOUSLY ANY
INFORMATION ABOUT THE NUCLEAR
SECRETS OF ANY COUNTRY, THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE
INTERESTED TO KNOW THOSE NUCLEAR
SECRETS.
>> SURE.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, I THINK IT'S
SUCH A SENSITIVE AREA THAT, YOU
KNOW, THERE'S CATEGORIES AND
SUBCATEGORIES OF THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION.
SOME OF IT IS ESSENTIALLY
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
INFORMATION THAT FALLS UNDER THE
CLASSIFIED SYSTEM UMBRELLA, AND
OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
SPECIAL ACCESS PROGRAMS, WHAT
YOU TALK ABOUT NUCLEAR
CAPABILITIES OF FOREIGN MILITARY
AGENCIES, THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
THE GOVERNMENT -- THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT IN NO WAY WANTS
SPREAD AROUND.
>> AND JUST TO BE CLEAR, IN THE
ARTICLE, YOU DON'T NAME THE
COUNTRY THAT THE INFORMATION IS
ABOUT.
IS THIS THE -- I MEAN YOU'VE
REPORTED IN THE PAST ABOUT
NUCLEAR-RELATED MATERIAL.
IS THIS THE SAME MATERIAL NOW
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WITH
JUST FURTHER -- GREATER CLARITY
ON IT?
>> WELL, I THINK WHAT WE WERE
DESCRIBING IN THE PAST STORY --
AND YOU CAN SEE IT NOW IN THE
SUBPOENA THAT WAS UNSEALED SINCE
THAT STORY -- IS THAT WHEN
TRUMP'S PEOPLE WERE SERVED WITH
THE SUBPOENA FOR ALL CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION IN HIS POSSESSION
BACK IN MAY, THAT SUBPOENA
LISTED A WHOLE SLEW OF
CATEGORIES OF DIFFERENT TYPES OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
BUT I THINK ONE OF THE IMPORTANT
CATEGORIES OF THAT WAS
INFORMATION ABOUT NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
AND SO THEY WERE TRYING TO -- IN
THAT SUBPOENA, THEY'RE TRYING TO
COVER THE WATERFRONT, BUT
THEY'RE ALSO SAYING, IF YOU HAVE
ANY INFORMATION THAT FITS INTO
THESE CATEGORIES, THIS IS THE
TYPE OF THING WE ARE SEEKING IN
THIS SUBPOENA THAT MUST BE
TURNED OVER TO THE GOVERNMENT.
AND SO THIS STORY TAKES IT A
STEP FURTHER AND SAYS, OKAY,
THEY SERVE THE SUBPOENA.
THEY CONDUCTED A SEARCH.
AND THIS DOCUMENT THAT WE
DESCRIBE IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY FOUND IN THE SEARCH.
>> IT